OK, let's go next to our caller from the nine
for one area code.
Who's calling today from nine for one.
Hi, David, this is William, I'm from Florida.
William from Florida.
What's going on?
Hi, David.
I really like your show.
I just want to put that out there right now.
Thank you.
So my question is a little broader in spectrum.
I I've recently gotten into small government
politics just because I work in substance
abuse field and we get a lot of governmental
funding and stuff like that.
Now, William, just I'm sorry to interrupt
you, but do you mean do you mean small government
as in small government, conservative conservatism
or just local politics?
Do you mean.
Just look, local county, Paula.
Oh, God.
OK.
OK, good.
Good, good, good.
I'm just mostly kind of I've kind of had to
just to learn where the money is coming from,
where it's flowing from, stuff like that,
to help clients get resources and things like
that.
Yeah.
But one thing that I've noticed since the
outbreak is a lot of that funding has kind
of disappeared and a lot of the resources,
it seems like people don't know where their
phones are.
And I was wondering, do you think this is
a direct correlation between what's going
on in the larger terms politically with Trump
and all those things?
Do you think that these things can be related?
I know that that's a very specific question.
Will this hand?
And for the moment, I realized I live in a
red state.
The answer is probably different in every
instance.
So there's no question.
If your question is, is funding to specific
programs, you're interested in being cut because
of Trump?
The answer would probably be, I have no idea
unless we look into it specifically and probably
not.
But we're I think the more direct connection
is that is not getting a lot of attention
now.
There's a lot of talk about if there's not
if people are unemployed, where do they get
money to spend stuff in the economy?
Small businesses need people coming in with
money to spend.
So we've got to get money to people either
through unemployment or through stimulus.
The part that's being ignored is directly
related to what you're bringing up, which
is if the government is collecting less revenue
from payroll taxes in states that have payroll
taxes, and if there are moratoriums on this
or that or whatever, states have less money
to then redistribute back out to all sorts
of different programs.
Now, you'd have to look at it at the state
by state and program by program level.
Like in other words, is there is is there
a specific answer in Florida?
I just don't know.
You'd have to look that up.
But certainly what people have to understand
is the state government can only take in reduced
revenue for so long before they are going
to start saying we can't afford to fund this
program and that program.
And that is certainly going on.
Right.
OK.
Well, that makes a lot of sense.
I just like I said, I've just seen over time
I'd like to I work directly with clients actually
working in a county jail.
And I work with inmates rehabilitating them
who have dealt with substance abuse.
I've dealt with substance abuse.
So we we have a correlation there, like we
can relate on those levels.
And so I get emotionally attached to these
people a little bit.
Yes.
And which is part of my job.
And then and then I try to I try to connect
them to as many resources as they can to be
successful upon exiting the jail system or
the prison system.
And so it's just been kind of heartbreaking
to see like.
And I understand.
I get it when you put it in terms like that,
as in the government can't give us money if
they're not making any, you know.
And so but that's I thank you for simplifying
it to me, because, like I said, I'm new to
these things.
I've never before Trump got elected.
I never thought once about politics.
I didn't need to know what I'm doing.
So you, um, now, you know, do you minds what
what substance specifically were you struggling
with?
Oh, yes.
Oh.
And I'm curious, how did it start with a prescription
from a doctor or how did it start?
Yeah, I actually had a I had a sports injury
in high school and I was first prescribed
Percocet and and I was I was a nerd in high
school, so I thought I would freak out if
I smoked it.
But opiates were the first thing that I took
that gave me that feeling of I don't have
to think about my problems.
It was the absence of pain.
So.
So that's that's where all of that came from.
And it was right at the beginning.
I'm twenty seven now.
Yeah.
It was right at the beginning of the opiate
crisis.
And so with the legal prescription, you got
hooked.
And then it continued after you no longer
needed them for the injury.
Oh, yeah.
The obsession had begun, that whole wheel
started turning.
Of, well, if this worked this way, if one
is good, two is better.
Yeah.
Right.
And and if I if that helped with that pain,
then maybe from trauma and things like that
that I experienced in my life that I had never
identified before.
Maybe these other things will work.
And for people who hear this and say, well,
why couldn't you just start weaning yourself
off slowly?
Like, it just doesn't work that way, does
it?
No.
Well, because you're no.
You're not dealing with the drug.
So it doesn't have anything to do with the
drugs.
The drugs are just the most highlighted part
of the problem.
Right.
Like.
Like because we all experience vices in our
life, whether it's with money or sex or power.
You know what I mean?
But but that is that is the easiest way for
someone with an addictive personality.
Because it's in the fire, it's instantly gratifying.
Right.
Just like spending spending money on a pair
of shoes that you didn't really want to begin
with.
Right.
You just want to hear that catching sound.
Yep.
And so.
So, yeah, that's kind.
It's not as simple as just quit.
But I understand why people say that because.
Explaining her addiction to a quote unquote,
like to a person who's never dealt with it
is almost like explaining yellow to a blind
person, like it's really difficult.
Even if they really want to understand, even
if they love you or respect you.
So that and that's partially been my job as
well as, too, is to talk to these representatives
and things like that about that and get them
to understand, you know, why it is that people
do need help, why they need those resources
and they need some attention.
You know what I mean?
Absolutely.
William, well said.
Thank you.
And thank you for calling in.
I appreciate it.
Thank you so much, sir.
All right.
Take care.
We're going to go to a quick break if you
are holding.
Don't hang up because we'll go right back
to the phones after this short break.